Ob künstliche intelligenz ki jetzt gut oder schlecht für die menschheit ist darüber scheiden sich die geister
jetzt tut sich allerdings eine perspektive auf die ist extrem spannend und angefangen hat alles mit
fast ray burst also schnellen radio blitzen was die mit außerirdischen zu tun haben jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich seines videos abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
Radio blitze sogenannte raiders gehören wohl mit zu den größten rätsel der astronomie
die ursache und der ursprung der extrem intensiven fast raiders die sind weitgehend unbekannt
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus den usa haben jetzt eine künstliche intelligenz zur unterstützung herangezogen
und das ist wirklich irre die ki hat nicht nur
72 weitere radio blitze einer rund drei milliarden lichtjahre entfernten quelle
aufgespürt ihre analysen liefern zudem auch super spannende hinweise zu dem mysteriösen phänomenen der radio blitze
denn das was wir bisher über die so genannten fast track your body
wissen hält sich wirklich in grenzen was feststeht diese radio blitze sind sehr intensiv und halten nur millisekunden sie entstehen wohl
außerhalb unserer galaxie
doch wie genau das ist unklar der großteil der bisher detektierten radio blitze tritt vereinzelt
auf die einzige ausnahme davon ist fab
12 11 02 hier konnten sich wiederholende ausbrüche registriert werden 200 an der zahl
so gelang es dann auch endlich die genaue quelle in diesem fall zu identifizieren eine zwerggalaxien
die drei milliarden lichtjahre entfernt ist hier vermuten die experten und expertinnen
ein extrem starkes magnetfeld das schließen sie aus der linearen polarisierung der radiosignale
die stark verdreht ist in der fachsprache wird dieser effekt als parade effekt bezeichnet und fab 12 11 nur zwei
ist dieser eben mal
500 mal stärker als bei allen anderen fast regelwerks das hatte ein niederländisches forschungsteam erst anfang des jahres herausgefunden
doch um welches extrem starke magnetfeld es sich handelt das ist noch völlig offen um all die offenen fragen
zu dem mysteriösen phänomenen der radio blitze zu beantworten hat ein forschungsteam aus berkeley jetzt eine künstliche intelligenz als
unterstützung hinzu geholt die ki hatte die aufgabe die beobachtungsdaten die das greenback
radioteleskopen west virginia im august 2017 sechs stunden lang aufgezeichnet hatte auszuwerten
damit die analyse des neuronalen netzwerk es brauchbare ergebnisse
liefert wurde die ki zunächst trainiert und zwar mit daten zu simulierten und echten radiobereich und tatsächlich zu den 21 radio
pulsen die man bislang aufspielen konnte fand die weitere
72 radio kits von evb 12 11 02 sind nun also insgesamt mehr als
300 radio blitze bekannt dazu schreibt das us forschungsteam wir präsentieren damit die erste erfolgreiche
anwendung von die burning auf die detektion von stellen radiosignalen in rohan speck programmdaten
unsere ergebnisse stellen die bisher größte zahl von radium blitzen innerhalb einer beobachtungszeit taten doch die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler vermuten noch eine weitere große anzahl an radio blitzen sie selbst der ki in ihrer analyse
entgangen sind ein hinweis darauf liefert die verteilung der pulse über den beobachtungszeitraum
die stark von einer zufalls verteilung abweicht und die von dem neuronalen netzwerk aufgespürten radio berg bringen etwas licht in das mysteriöse
phänomen zum einen konnte das forschungsteam feststellen dass knapp 50 prozent der pulse in den ersten 30 minuten der
beobachtungszeit eingetroffen waren was genau das bedeutet das blatt noch offen
diese beobachtung könnte allerdings ein hinweis darauf sein dass es sich bei den schwächeren pulse um eine art
nachbeben eines starken blitzes handelt ganz auszuschliessen sei aber nicht dass es sich dabei auch um ganz normale schwankungen der radio
emissionshandel so das forschungsteam ein sehr konkretes ergebnis lieferte die analyse der ki bezüglich der regelmäßigkeit der radl blitze die
regelmäßigen intervalle in denen sie auftraten sind kürzer als zehn millisekunden
so das ergebnis das forschungsteam zudem zeigt die ki auch dass die regiobus in einigen fällen sehr eng aufeinander
folgende paare bilden eine äußerst wichtige frage zu der noch weiter geforscht werden muss
rotiert die quelle der radio blitze oder nicht denn die antwort darauf könnte
spannende rückschlüsse auf die mögliche quelle von fab 12 11 02 zu lassen bei einem rotierenden
objekt das sehr regelmässige pulse aussendet könnte es sich beispielsweise um einen
millisekunden magnetare handeln das ist ein schnell rotierenden neutronenstern mit starken magnetfeldern doch das sind nicht die einzigen
möglichen quellen forschungsteams hatten auch schon einmal schwarze löcher oder hast du ihnen einschläge auf
neutronensternen ins spiel gebracht die fachwelt jedenfalls feiert die arbeit des us forschungsteams dazu der wissenschaftler andrew
simeon und das ist extrem gespannt was er sagt diese arbeit ist sehr aufregend und zwar nicht nur weil sie uns hilft das dynamische verhalten
schneller radiowelt genauer zu verstehen
diese forschung ist sehr vielversprechend
bezüglich dem einsatz von ki mit der man signale erkennen kann die klassische algorithmen verpasst haben moment
signale erkennen kann die klassische algorithmen verpasst haben nämlich die von aliens der forscher ist nämlich teil
des sogenannten brics kulissen projekt zu sein privat
finanziertes forschungsprojekt das sich der suche nach außerirdischem leben im all verschrieben hat auch in diesem
zusammenhang wird ki angewandt sie soll signale aufspüren die von außerirdischen
zivilisationen stammen könnten und vielleicht könnte so ein durchbruch erzielt werden denn ki ist der einzige weg riesige
datenmengen nach strukturen eben zum beispiel signalen von außerirdischen zu durchsuchen und trainieren könnte man die auch hier auf der erde
sie könnte radiosignale oder
funksignale auf der erde suchen und damit lernen und vielleicht könnte so ein durchbruch erzielt werden denn ki ist der einzige weg riesige
datenmengen nach strukturen eben zum beispiel signalen von außerirdischen zu durchsuchen und trainieren könnte man die ki auch hier auf der erde
sie könnte radiosignale oder funksignale auf der erde suchen und damit lernt diese entdeckung könnte
wirklich ein riesiger schritt sein auf dem weg der entdeckung von aliens denn auch wenn es wahrscheinlich
unzählige zivilisationen da draußen gibt sie in den wahrscheinlich milliarden mal mehr anderen signalen zu entdecken ist eine
riesige herausforderung
das künstliche intelligenz hier bei den radio über so einen unterschied macht ist mehr als vielversprechend
und ich bleibe dran und wenn ihr garantiert kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hilft nur whatsapp
da informiere ich euch täglich und das vor allen andern
dafür hier klicken und weiter geht's mit auch dafür drauf klicken wird ein gamma blitz die erde zerstören der elster blitz aller zeiten das
erste video übrigens von klicks um
science-fiction bis da
bleibt dran